[Applause]
all right hi everyone uh so my name is
marisha winkles and today i'm going to
be talking to you about data centric ai
and more specifically why you should
care about it i'm also going to explain
a little bit about what data centric ai
is and just tell you some anecdotes of
how i've encountered it or use it in
practice
and a little bit about myself i work for
go data driven and at go data driven i'm
a data science educator and that means
that i give or teach data science
trainings to anyone who's willing to
listen and pay
being a data science educator
got me thinking about how i was taught
data science and machine learning in the
first place
so i studied artificial intelligence at
the university of amsterdam and when i
was taught machine learning it was very
focused on the algorithms very focused
on the models
so the first thing we did during our
machine learning course was study this
book by bishop it's called pattern
recognition and machine learning and
it's very heavy on maths and equations
it gives you a great
deep understanding of the underlying
math underlying all the algorithms
but it's not necessarily very practical
so to get a little bit more practical
we had to implement the algorithms
ourselves so i built my own svms i build
my own neural networks
and we then apply them on some data set
i don't even remember what data said it
was probably the irs data set
but i studied the algorithms i
implemented the algorithms and then to
get a little bit better understanding of
how to use it
i practiced on
toy data sets
so this
i did mostly with gaggle to get a bit
more familiarity with the common
packages i practiced on data sets by
kaggle i think
many of you will recognize the titanic
data set here there's actually a newer
version called spaceship titanic which
is very similar very beginner friendly
but about
passengers who were transported to a
different dimension
but this was my personal journey of how
i learned machine learning and data
science and not everyone has the chance
to study as a university
but still many people follow a sort of
similar process maybe they don't
implement the algorithms themselves but
whenever you look at online courses
bootcamps etc
it's mostly focused on the algorithms we
see here that these coursera courses the
skills you'll learn are logistic
regression neural networks etc
so don't get me thinking now i work as a
data scientist
a common thing to say is that 80 of the
effort that we as data scientists put
into our project is about data cleaning
or data preparation and only 20 is about
the models
so
if machine learning is 20 modeling and
80 or the majority of our time is spent
on data preparation
why is data preparation not taught
why is there such little focus on the
practicalities of dealing with our data
well
data scientists because of the way that
they were taught they often treat their
data their data sets as static because
that's what they were taught in courses
that's what most online competitions
focus on
it's also what most of academia focuses
on so often papers are about squeezing
the last bit of performance on common
static benchmark data sets
and not necessarily about augmenting
your data or changing your data
and lastly it's what most tools are
being built for
however i want to argue that data sets
should not be static
so as an example
i participated in a competition once it
was the data science bowl of 2017
and the goal of this data science board
this competition was to predict whether
someone was likely to get lung cancer in
the following year
based on a ct scan
so i happened to be working at a company
at the time which did this as a product
so we built a product that analyzed lung
ct scans and
determined whether there were
abnormalities in the lung
and because of that we decided to
participate in this competition as well
but also because of that we knew that
the competition that we were
participating in if we were just focused
on the data that we were presented with
was impossible
because the data along ct scan a ct is
kind of the abdomen is actually a 3d
volume so it's about 300 images of 500
by 500 pixels
and the labels that we were provided
with was just
will this person get lung cancer or not
whereas in practice
the amount of data that we were given
1300 scans
not nearly enough to solve that problem
and even if we had more scans it's it's
just too complex to solve it in by
straight up forward putting it into a
convolutional neural network
and getting a prediction out of that
so our company decided to participate in
this competition and we actually ended
up in third place and it also gave us
the opportunity to look at what other
solutions were what other other
participants had come up with
and it turns out that all the top
scoring solutions basically completely
discard disregarded the data sets that
they were given
so the second place solution by julian
dewitt together with daniel hammock
um they said for this solution so for
this data science bowl the engineering
of the train set was essential if not
the most essential part of their
solution
and why is that well
i won't dive too deeply into how to do
this specifically but essentially if you
have a 3d ct scan you can't just say
does someone have lung cancer or not
what you can do however is try to find
abnormalities in the lung as you can see
here
and then classify those abnormalities as
potentially malignant or not and then
if someone has a lot of potentially
malignant abnormalities then that person
is pretty likely to get lung cancer
so julian the second place solution he
described that he used five different
data sets in order to do this and none
of them were actually the original
kaggle data set so
not only did he use datasets that he
found online but he also generated
automatic tables
employed active learning and even
created his own special build tool fewer
to debug the labels and manually select
interesting case samples
and that was a very similar approach to
what we did as well
so a lot of effort went into the
labeling and the labeling quality
and creating a representative training
set rather than tuning network
parameters
and the key thing to note here is that
it was not about getting more data it
was about getting better data and
recognizing that the data that we were
given was not sufficient
to solve our problem
and that brings me to a slightly more
recent competition the data centric ai
competition
so the data centric ai competition ran
for six weeks in september 2021 and the
central topic here was data centric ai
and data centric ai is described as the
discipline of systematically engineering
the data used to build an ai system
what this meant for the competition was
this so the model was fixed
but the data could be changed
so what does that mean well uh we had a
we had a fixed model a resin at 50. we
could access and run it locally but we
had to submit the data
to the competition and all the compute
was handled on the challenge site
one of the things that i really liked
about this was that it made it
more accessible to participate as well
because you didn't need any beefy gpus
to compete you simply needed about 10 mb
of storage space and an internet
connection and you could submit your own
version of the train and the validation
set
because on the challenge side they were
handling everything model related
next this competition was about roman
numerals so we had handwritten roman
numerals of about one until 10 as you
can see here
and this is what we had to classify
in total we were provided with about
3000 images
in a given train and validation split
the validation split was used for early
stopping so that was an important part
and we were also provided with a label
book with exact with examples that we
could expect for each
class
and the task at hand here was to enhance
the training set or enhance the data set
in such a way that the performance on
the fixed model would improve
we were limited to five submissions per
week over six week periods and an
important restriction was that we were
not allowed to submit more than 10 000
examples
so we participated in this as well what
did we do
so i participated in this challenge
together with my colleagues friends and
rule and the very first thing we did was
to use low tech tools to get started
together
so we quickly found out that google
sheets actually allows us to display an
image
if you provide it with the url which
very easily allowed us to go through the
data in a collaborative way
so we created a pandas data frame with
the url of an image and some additional
information such as the file name and
the subset of the data and we created
some scripts to very easily import and
export this from google sheets to pandas
and so forth
so we did this because it allowed us a
very collaborative way to improve label
quality which is the first step towards
creating a better data set
so we improved label quality in the
following way
first of all we extracted the
predictions on the images
for the baseline resnet50 model so these
were the predictions if we didn't change
anything
so no alterations to our data just yet
and this allowed us to focus on
discrepancies between the model and the
ground truth
and because we were using google sheets
we also imported the confidence level of
the model that the conference that model
had in our predictions and we could very
easily just sort it by confidence to
focus on the most clear mistakes that
were being made
however
we then had to overwrite those wrong
labels and we found that the solution
that we tried at first to just discuss
and override it and when we reached the
consensus
was not always the right way to go about
it because it turns out that even with
just three humans in the room there's
still a lot of need for discussion about
certain data samples we often disagreed
whether something was a two or four or
something like that
and it was just taking way too long to
go through all the data if we had to
discuss every single sample
so because we had three dozen samples uh
this took way too long so we decided to
go about it in a slightly different way
and that is that we created separate
sheets and everyone individually and
went through the sheet which was very
easy to do because you saw the image and
you just press 12 this is this is just
crap or this is a 1 or this is a 7 etc
we combined those different sheets into
one representation
where we could see the different
annotators and also focus on the
disagreement
so if all annotators agreed if all three
of us agreed it was automatically
overwritten with the label that we
thought it should be instead of the
original label
and if we didn't disagree we could
discuss the examples but we ended up
throwing out most of those examples
where we had a discussion about if we
had a discussion it was taking longer
than three seconds we said this is
clearly not a good example if we can
even agree how can we expect the model
to learn
and i taught us something very important
and that is that the labeling is the
learning
the process of manually going through
your data gave us so much better
understanding of the problem at hand
that it allowed us to decide what to do
next
first of all we noticed that some data
points simply didn't belong in the
training set at all so these were some
of the examples of data points that we
got and that the model was not very
confident on
and these noisy data points just needed
to be removed altogether our model would
be better off without them
we also learned that a lack of consensus
between annotators was pretty much
always about the same classes so we
would often confuse sevens for threes
and twos for sixes
and maybe more importantly we also
noticed that there was a distinct
difference in writing styles in the data
set something that wasn't labeled at all
but by going through the data you notice
this more and more
so you see the column of numbers on the
left here which are all threes and the
columns on the right are all sevens but
they're written in a clearly different
way than the other examples
and this led us to notice something
maybe even more important and that is
that there was a big
big difference in distribution between
the train and the validation set
so you see here some samples from our
training set and these were some samples
from our validation set and it turns out
that the first way of writing was way
more common in our train set whereas the
second way of writing the numbers was
way more common in our validation set
just by analyzing you know the classes
and how many samples belong to each
class we wouldn't have noticed this but
by going through the data manually this
becomes very apparent
and this can actually
prove to be a problem as well
so what did we do next
next we used embeddings to get a sense
of typicality and style
we passed the data again through
resnet50 our baseline model to get
predictions as before but instead of
focusing on those predictions
we remove the head of the tasks where
the features extracted from the image by
the convolutional neural network are
converted to an output prediction
and we end up with embeddings numeric
values that describe the image
so think about it like this in the last
layers of the network before these
values these embeddings are converted to
an actual prediction
it will be logical to assume that
embeddings that represent an image of a
three will be more similar to each other
than the embeddings of a different
picture of a nine for instance
so we got those embeddings but we wanted
to visualize them however these are
highly dimensional so we can't just
visually visualize them at right so we
had to use some form of dimensionality
reduction to get back to two dimensions
in this case we chose umap
so we performed umap on our embeddings
and decided to visualize this with
altair specifically because the altera
library also gives us some really nice
interaction
so let me see if i can
run this
i think we can yes
as you can see the tooltip allows us to
display the specific data points as well
and the data points as you see them here
are colored according to the subset of
data they belong to train validation or
label book
and as you can see here
it seems like the left quadrant of the
data is represented in the train set
but not necessarily very heavily in the
validation set as well
and this was confirmed when we visualize
them separately
as you can see here
the data by plotting them separately the
problem becomes more clear the
distribution of the data in the training
set and the validation set is not the
same and how can we expect to get a good
model if those distributions don't match
up
so that taught us our second lesson
don't be afraid to rebalance the train
test split we were given some train data
and some validation
and it would be easy to just keep it the
way it is but sometimes it's a good idea
to change data points from one set to a
different set so rebalance it
next step we had to actually improve our
data set so we cleaned up some of the
some of the labels but how do we go
about creating new data points well
first of all an obvious one is going for
data augmentation so we have the the
obvious data augmentation methods like
scaling cropping rotation etc
but one that we focused on a little bit
more was actually specifically creating
counterfactuals
as you can see here we created a
relatively simple streamlet app with the
streamlit drawable canvas
and that will allow us to
you can see the balloons
to create new data samples from other
data samples
so by taking an existing data point you
can alter it in such a way that for
instance what used to be an 8 represents
a 1 or 2 or 5 etc
and the idea behind this is that we
wanted to focus on the kinds of mistakes
that the model was making so if it often
confuses a two for four for instance
why don't you show that difference by
making it counterfactual
so this allowed us to create new data
quickly and it was most interesting for
images that our previous model found
quite hard
so for those eights that were
misclassified as sevens for instance we
would take the eight that was
misclassified also create a seventh
version of it by simply removing one of
the
eyes and that would be a counterfactual
to help guide the model to learn that no
this is what a 7 looks like and this is
what an 8 looks like it should focus not
on a style
but it should focus on the fees the eyes
and the relative positions of those
and that taught us our last lesson
invest time in creating additional
tooling that allows you to quickly
change and iterate over your data sets
collaborating here was not a hassle but
because we wrote some scripts that would
automatically save the files to the
right folders
so our folders were divided in such a
way that the folder called seven had all
the images of a 7 folder called 8 had
all the images of an 8 etc
and if we overwrote something in our
google sheet we said this should
actually be a 7 not an 8 the file would
get moved accordingly
so we didn't have to bother with that
and we also didn't have to manually
change every picture we could just
upload it to our have the stream that
canvas and uh draw on it and it would
again save it in the right places
so it took a little bit of time to
create a student around it but it wasn't
too much of a hassle and it saved a lot
of time in the long run
because we could very easily try out
different data sets and see how they
performed
this allowed us to focus on what we
wanted to focus on which is the data
and that actually worked quite well for
us
we were one of the winners in the most
innovative category of the competition
we didn't actually have the best
performance that credit goes to some of
the other teams like innotescus
synaptic and and diverge
so it might be interesting to us to
discuss what the best performing teams
tried and what they focused on
so those three best performing teams all
had slightly different approaches
so the first team by synaptic and that
ended up in third place
they mostly focused on generating a lot
of data and then restricting that all
those documentations to the 10 000 most
relevant ones
so first of all that it's a manual data
cleaning like most of us did
um but they also did some manual data
generation so they asked friends and
colleagues to just write roman numerals
for them and that gave them extra
handwritten roman numerals
they also used automated data generation
so specifically auto augment they
investigated used some some parameters
to choose the best augmentation
techniques
and then used filtering by vote using an
ensemble model
or multiple models and just voting on
what the best ones were to restrict from
the 70 000 images that they ended up
with to the 10 000 best ones
if you want to read more about their
approach that's on the link here that
will be the case for all of the
competing teams
the second team by innotescus who ended
up in second place
they didn't as much focus on creating a
lot of different images and then
restricting them to the 10 000 allowed
but they were actually mostly focused on
rebalancing that train and validation
split
so they very quickly noticed with their
their tooling that there was quite a
disconnect between how the different
classes were internally balanced so you
see that in some classes a lot of there
were a lot of uppercase letters whereas
in other classes there were a lot of
lowercase letters
and also between the validation and
train set this varied a little bit
so the way that they created new data
was by detecting these
imbalances
and then creating data augmentation
specifically on those cases where
that were underrepresented in that
specific class or in that specific
subset of the data so for instance
if there were not a lot of lower case
letters ladder once
they would take the lowercase and create
the augmentation specifically on that
data sample rather than in the uppercase
data samples
so that landed them in second place
and lastly difficult roy's approach
that was again focused on a completely
different part of the data set which i
thought was quite interesting where they
noticed that there were quite a lot of
different types of noise in the data set
so you can see here at the top these are
all the types of noise that you could
encounter in a data set
so what they decided to do was separate
the noise from the actual number
and then create new samples to have all
types of noise
nicely
presented in all for all classes in all
parts of the data set
so they use data augmentation to augment
their individual numbers and then
overlaid that on a noise canvas so you
have a different version of that noise
with a different version of the number
as well
and this actually
won them the competition
so
why am i talking about this why are we
doing this data centric ai competition
whereas previously the most famous
competitions are more like title
competitions
why are we doing a competition that's
really only just focused on altering the
data
and keeps the model fixed
well
that's a valid question because the idea
that focusing on your data is an
important thing to do is not new i mean
one of the first things that i learned
was garbage in garbage out right
and monitoring your data to discover
errors or
applying
other techniques like active learning
that actually dates back decades so why
do we talk about it now and why is it
called data centric ai
well
in order to illustrate that i want to
remind you of deep learning which is
something that really had its revival in
2010s
the idea of deep learning wasn't new so
deep learning has been around for a
really long time the first perceptron
was created in 1958 i mean back
propagation the paper about that was
what 1986
and i've seen papers about applying uh
convolutional neural networks on x-ray
images back in 1994.
so the ideas behind deep learning aren't
necessarily very new but there is
something that changed that caused it to
rise to prominence and
be as important as it is today somewhere
around 2010-ish
things changed so we had more large
annotated data sets available we had
better compute available and
it really meant that even though the
ideas were around for longer
deep learning as we know it today pretty
much started in 2010
so
why would that also be the case for data
centric ai the idea that you should
focus on your data we know this there
are techniques that we could use that
we've known for ages
what is different now
well the first and i would say almost
most important thing
is that models have become more
user-friendly and commoditized
and we as data scientists simply don't
have the resources to compete with this
look at models like gpd3 bert and large
resonant models
the architectures of these models have
an incredible number of parameters
and it is completely unfeasible for most
of us to create and train those from
scratch
typically we also don't have the huge
data sets available to us that they were
trained on
however because of transfer learning we
can still use these pre-trained models
and fine-tune them on our own much
smaller data sets
and it is being made increasingly easy
and automated to do that to use models
out of the box
and that means that the competitive
advantage of data scientists is in
everything that surrounds the models so
that could mean defining great metrics
or discovering systematic errors in your
models or even just shipping your models
to the user
but a very important part of that is the
data because the data is unique to your
use case
improving the data can
[Music]
can be easier and have more impact than
improving the model or the algorithm
second it simply improves performance in
these three use cases as you can see
here tinkering with the model led to
almost negligible results or increases
in performance whereas tinkering with
the data led to a huge increase in
performance
and
as you can see here as well
performance on clean representative data
is simply better than models trained on
noisy data
in this particular case that means that
training on 1500 noisy data points gives
you about the same level of performance
as training on 500 data points
and that becomes particularly relevant
for your small data problems and yes you
can just collect more data why don't you
just collect a thousand more samples and
then you don't have to bother with
cleaning
but even your big data problems are
often small data problems in the long
tail
for instance when you consider a chatbot
um sure there are questions that your
chat bot will get asked very frequently
like oh i want to change my address or
something very common like that
but there's a huge huge amount of
questions that you just don't have a lot
of data for because just a couple of
people ask it so you better make sure
that that data is good
and lastly remember this image
tuning the network parameters is often a
very individual exercise choosing the
right architecture choosing the right
number of layers choosing the right
model
is a very individual thing to do and
it's very hard to talk about or get
advice on
whereas focusing on the data like we did
here we were able to collaborate
as a team and data is much easier to
talk about than models
and this is true for data science teams
amongst themselves but it's also true
for those other people other
stakeholders that might have very
relevant insights such as end users or
subject matter experts
for instance an example
when we were working on lung cancer
detection a very important part of lung
cancer detection is whether something is
malignant and a very good indicator of
whether something is malignant is the
type of nodule or abnormality that it is
so
what did we do as data scientists we
built a huge convolutional neural
network threw in our 3d data and
expected us to give it give us good
results
but it turns out that we actually didn't
have a lot of data we had a lot of solid
nodules data but we didn't have a lot of
ground glass module data
which meant that our network was really
underperforming on ground glass and part
solid modules which were the most
important to detect correct
so
luckily as i was working in a company
that focused on this we had an in-house
domain expert a doctor
and i went up to him and said hey um can
you have a look at my at the results of
my model can you see some patterns here
and
see what kind of mistakes it's making
because you know i'm not a certified
radiologist i i'm pretty good at reading
nigel's at this stage but i didn't you
know i'm not the expert
and
he didn't even look at the data he just
said to me
why are you building a model and i was
like what do you mean why are you
building a model i need to know which of
these three things it is so i'm building
a model to get that information
but apparently what radiologists do to
assess whether it's a solid part solid
or blind class nodule is just eyeball
the amount of white pixels
um
so
if he told me if all of them are white
it's solid if half of them are white
it's part solid and if you know almost
none of them are white
it's ground glass
that was a bit didn't turn out to be a
great heuristic but together with our
domain experts together with the doctor
we we discovered a good heuristic that
was able to properly classify
whatever we needed here
even though our neural network did not
have enough data to learn from
and another example is which is not a
conversation with the domain expert
with one of the end users
is that our model simply picked up
abnormalities or abnormal tissue
and apparently when you ship a model to
a user and you ship it to a radiologist
they get really annoyed when your lung
cancer detection software packs up
abnormalities in the liver because
that's not lung cancer obviously
um
so based on that feedback and based on
the conversation with some of the
hospitals that were running our models
that were so kind to to help us out with
this
um we created a lung mask to filter out
any abnormalities that may be located or
detected outside of these areas
and it was in collaboration with our
domain
expert our in-house expert or doctor who
told us yeah you can't actually put it
around the border there because a lot of
abnormalities are at the border exactly
so you need to have a little bit of
wiggle room over there
um
yeah so
in this case those conversations helped
us to create a better product but also
to not filter out too much
this is all to say
that focusing on the data enables better
collaboration between the data
scientists but also other involved
parties it helps create a better shared
understanding
because
this is what we want to avoid that we
have a solution where we say i solve the
medical problem by simply looping over a
bunch of settings
hopefully
as a data scientist focused on the data
you go back to the hospital
and actually get out of your ivory tower
and talk to these people and that's much
easier to do when you talk about the
data than when you talk about the model
parameters
so we talk about data centric ai and
what does that mean well
andrewing states that having 50
thoughtfully engineered examples can be
sufficient to explain to the neural
network what you wanted to learn
so the focus has to shift from big data
to good data
what does good data mean well first of
all although it might sound very obvious
it means consistent labels
it might sound obvious but it's not
always the case
sometimes that's simply because of
unclear instructions as maybe you can
see here where someone was instructed to
label or put a bounding box around the
cups of coffee is that one big bounding
box or two smaller bounding box
but sometimes it's simply a little bit
more complicated so say that you have a
comment like people still eat at pizza
hut gross
is that a toxic comment
i mean
it's not a nice comment but is it over
is it toxic
what does it mean for comments to be
toxic precisely
and every task is like this in one way
or another
i've seen this in
medical image data sets as well we had a
really really good medical image data
set where the data set was annotated by
four different radiologists who each oil
had individually 35 years of experience
under their belt
and you would simply not believe how
often they disagreed
which is a little bit unfortunate but
all right
second another characteristic of good
data is that it is complete and
representative
so imagine that this is your data set
right so this is your training set it's
a pretty good example of bananas
but it's not a great example if this is
the kind of example that you will
encounter in practice
we've seen this in the roman numerals
data set where the distribution between
the training set and the validation set
did not match up
and lastly we also need the data to be
unbiased
so a model trained on bias data will in
itself also be biased this is often the
case for language but also for images
for instance and other forms of data
so we really want to avoid a situation
like this
where
completing a sentence with this man
works as a mask ends up with lawyer
carpenter doctor and the same sentence
with woman ends up with nurse waitress
teacher and even prostitute
however luckily
part of data centric ai is also to
develop tools that can help detect these
biases
take for example revise a tool that was
presented at the
data center ai workshop at nurbs last
edition
not only does it provide you with
possible inequalities in your data set
this is on image data
but it also is very actionable because
you can see what kind of data you're
missing so it guides you how to do your
data collection if you collect more data
what areas you should focus on
that also means that data collection
should be an iterative process
so how do we get to data centric ai and
where do we go from here
so we know now that the focus
is shifting from what we call model
centric ai to data centric igni ai
because
advancement in the field has mostly been
about scaling larger and larger models
that are infeasible for individual data
scientists
to create and train and models are being
more commoditized and easier to huge use
which means that a competitive advantage
for data scientists isn't everything
that surrounds the model and
particularly the data that is unique to
every use case
but how does a movement like this and it
is a movement how does it develop
well it of course starts out with some
individuals that take an interest like
like i said with deep learning there
have been techniques around this topic
for around for ages
deep learning didn't always have
was always around the ideas were around
for a really long time but it didn't
really gain widespread appreciation
until around 2010.
and the same goes for data center ai
before it had a name
there were several people that embraced
it
then the term is coined
and you can see that it gets more
adapted we had the data centric ai
competition we had the data centric
workshop
at nerifs and we have conferences about
it
and lastly we have systematic tools that
are being developed so that's the stage
where we are in now tools are being
developed you can see these papers that
were created we have these companies
that are around now
and
it's not just academia taking an
interest it's also
companies
but what if you say
i like building models does that mean
that data center ai is the way to go and
model centric ai isn't necessary anymore
are we just going to become data
cleaners rather than data scientists
well don't despair first of all the
balance between model and data centric
ai swings back and forth
so the reason why the learning could
advance in the first place was the
availability of large data sets
and tools that made them possible and
currently improving quality by improving
the model is much more difficult than
improving by using techniques that
manipulate the data that might change
over time
and if you don't want to wait we are in
dire need of tools that make it easier
to iterate over the data and models play
a huge role there too so there's enough
for us left to do
that being said i'd like to thank you
all for your attention and thanks for pi
data london for organizing
we've got limited time but two or three
questions we can handle
thank you um
very great talk thank you very much um
when you said that you disagreed between
you and your colleagues on like
what numero uh what the numerals meant
and also in a medical application right
doctors disagree what's your like first
go-to strategy is it to remove these
labels is it to um
you know augment them like clarify them
uh edit them so that they
fall into one on other another class
what is the best
uh that's a very good question so in the
case of the roman numerals we decided to
just get rid of them because we had a
restriction of three of 10 000 samples
that we could submit so we wanted to
submit the most clear samples
in the case of medical data that was a
little bit different because
there's simply not as much annotated
medical data around so what we decided
to do there is give a higher weight to
the data points that were very clear and
a lower weight to the data points that
were a little bit ambiguous
one of the most
remarkable things in your exxon talk was
a quotation that we should move from big
data to good data and that in certain
cases perhaps a binary classifier we
might only need 50 good examples
where does the number 50 comes from
and how do we know what it should be
that's a very good question um first of
all that quote it wasn't a quote by me
it was a quote by andrew so i don't know
where he got that from i don't want to
take credit for that
um second of all i think that does
depend a little bit about the complexity
of your problem if you have a very
simple problem that you're trying to
solve 50 examples is good enough and
then if you have something like 3d
medical lung cancer data set i don't
think you'll ever have enough with 50
examples but i think what it mostly
illustrates is that we don't necessarily
need as much data as we used to because
we used to need a lot of data because we
needed to train all the models from
scratch and if we're just fine-tuning
it's more about fine-tuning on the right
data than it is on a lot of data
[Applause]